When Vladimir Putin ordered the invasion of Ukraine,...
...he repeatedly said it was in part a response to NATO's expansion.
Two months on, there's a good chance...
...his invasion will lead to Russia's land border with NATO doubling in length.
Because just as Ukraine borders Russia, so does Finland.
And Finland may soon join NATO.
I won't give any kind of timetable when we will make our decisions,...
...but I think it will happen quite fast, within weeks, not within months.
That's the current Finnish Prime Minister.
This former Prime Minister goes further.
I think that Finland and most possibly Sweden as well,...
...will become members of NATO by the end of this year.
And that would be a moment of huge significance.
NATO is already the world's biggest military alliance.
Its headquarters are in Brussels,...
...and its thirty members include the US, the UK, Germany, and France.
Some other members are in Eastern Europe.
They're here in light purple.
They joined after the collapse of the Soviet Union, much to Vladimir Putin's fury.
We won't move one inch towards the east, they told us in the 1990s.
And what happened?
They deceived us.
They brazenly tricked us.
NATO denies its expansion as a threat, but that's how Russia sees it,...
...and that expansion may be about to continue.
Finland's already a member of the EU, and it cooperates with NATO.
And while it's unofficially neutral in military terms, it is a military player.
Most men in Finland do military service.
Official statistics show a wartime strength of 280,000 soldiers,...
...and 900,000 reservists.
And the Finnish defense forces describe themselves as the "backbone of our society."
Finland's military strategy had felt settled.